The Golden Empire of Yi Ti is the new Game
of Thrones prequel show that HBO is developing.
It will be an animated show based on the Golden
Empire of Yi Ti, one of the oldest civilizations
in the known world which originated in the
wake of the Long Night and survived to this
very day. It’s at least 8,000 years old.
It was already ancient when the Valyrians
(including the Targaryens) were still shepherds
and had not yet trained dragons (over 5,000
years ago). Yi Ti is a great realm located
in the Further East of Essos and it’s the
supposed successor to the mythic Great Empire
of the Dawn, which, according to legend, fell
during the Long Night. It’s ruled by a God-Emperor,
who is worshiped as divine.
Much as George RR Martin’s Westeros is inspired
by medieval Europe, George’s mystic Yi Ti
is inspired by Imperial China. It’s a mysterious,
little-known part of Martin’s world that
will now be discovered to fans on HBO. House
of the Dragon, 10,000 Ships, Tales of Dunk
and Egg and Robert's Rebellion are not the
only Game of Thrones prequels that HBO is
developing. HBO is also working on Game of
Thrones’ Prequel ‘Golden Empire of Yi
Ti. As most of you already know, The House
of the Dragon is Game of Thrones successor
show based on George R.R. Martin's Fire & Blood,
a history of House Targaryen set 300 years
before the events in GoT. 10,000 Ships takes
place a thousand years before. Set 1,000 years
before the events of Game of Thrones, the
series tells the story of a warrior queen
Princess Nymeria and the surviving Rhoynars
who traveled from Essos to Dorne following
their defeat by Valyrian and their dragons.
Based on an ongoing series of fantasy novellas
by George R. R. Martin, set in the world of
A Song of Ice and Fire, Tales of Dunk and
Egg prequel series will follow the adventures
of the hedge knight, Ser Duncan the Tall (Dunk),
who would become a legendary Lord Commander
of the Kingsguard, and his squire Egg, who
would become King Aegon V Targaryen of Westeros.
The stories begin with their meeting eighty-nine
years before the events of Game of Thrones
and will cover the events until the deaths
of Dunk and Egg in the mysterious Tragedy
at Summerhall. This new prequel show based
on the legendary Golden Empire is the only
prequel that will not take place at Westeros,
but rather on Essos, to be more precise, in
the far east where the maps end.
Can we just pause the video for one second
and take this moment to like and subscribe
to the channel
as this is the place you’ll hear the news
regarding all the Game of Thrones prequels
and let’s continue.
Yi Ti is a region in the far east of the continent
of Essos. Officially known as the "Golden
Empire of Yi Ti", it lies near the eastern
limits of the known world and is sometimes
mentioned in the same breath as Asshai, indicating
its extreme distance from Westeros. Qarth
is located on the narrow straits at the western
end of the Jade Sea, and Yi Ti lies on that
sea's northeastern shores. People or things
from Yi Ti are referred to as "Yi Tish".
We have only seen one Yi Tish in Game of Thrones.
A Red Priestess that you’ve seen in Volantis
was of ethnic Yi Tish origin. In season 5,
at the Long Bridge in Volantis in Essos, she
preaches to the slaves gathered around her
that Daenerys Targaryen is a prophesied savior
sent by R'hllor. Tyrion Lannister and Varys
watch and listen from a distance; Tyrion mocks
her until she turns to face him, seemingly
knowing his words despite the distance. She
stares at him intently, forcing the two to
leave the scene in unease. This is the first
East Asian to appear as a character with speaking
lines in the Game of Thrones series. There
are people in the known world of the novels
who are ethnically East Asian in appearance,
and they live in the far east of Essos, far
east of Qarth and the Dothraki Sea, in the
great empire of Yi Ti (the narrative's analogue
to ancient China). As George R.R. Martin explained,
Yi Ti is so far away from Westeros that encountering
Yi Ti people in King's Landing is as unlikely
as encountering people from China in Medieval
England - medieval long-distance travel was
quite limited. In the novels, the only time
Yi Ti people ever appear is when Daenerys
Targaryen is even further east at the Dothraki
city Vaes Dothrak and mentions in passing
that few of the merchants at the city's market
are from Yi Ti. Yi Ti is one of the oldest
and most advanced societies in the known world.;
even the ruins of fallen cities in Yi Ti dwarf
the largest cities in Westeros. Many valuable
commodities - such as rare spices, gems, and
silks - are found in Yi Ti, making the region
incredibly wealthy; its princes are said to
live opulently in houses of solid gold, feasting
on meat powdered with pearls and jade. The
capital of Yi Ti is in the ancient city of
Yin, with the god-emperor living in a palace
nearly the size of King's Landing, a heavily
guarded city-within-a-city. Unlike the other
ancient civilizations of Essos, such as the
Ghiscari Empire and the Valyrian Freehold,
Yi Ti never collapsed due to internal instability.
Nor has it ever been conquered by outside
forces. Thus Yi Ti culture has endured unbroken
longer than any other civilization. Yi Ti's
religion includes several gods but is focused
around two primary deities: the Maiden-Made-of-Light
and the Lion of Night. A few Westerosi have
ever traveled all the way to Yi Ti, although
a handful of adventurers have made the long
journey. Among them was the famous navigator
Lord Corlys Velaryon, known as the "Sea Snake"
who will be the main character in the House
of the Dragon. He sailed to Yi Ti and brought
back enough rare and valuable spices to make
the Velaryons, for a time, one of the richest
and therefore the most powerful families in
Westeros.
Yi Ti is known to be a real place, but most
people know very little about it, and it’s
still semi-legendary to people living in Westeros
(much more so than Qarth, but not nearly as
much as feared Asshai). Even the maesters
only know a basic outline of its history and
culture - in part because Yi Ti's scholars
greatly prize their delicate, millennia-old
historical scrolls, so they do not share them
with outsiders. Yi Ti has a long and extensive
history dating back 8,000 years. Since the
Long Night, Yi Ti has been ruled by eleven
dynasties of emperors: the longest lasted
seven centuries, the shortest only half a
century. Sometimes transitions between dynasties
were peaceful, other times they were violent.
Several civilizations have rival claims to
be the eldest, particularly Yi Ti, Qarth,
and the Ghiscari Empire. The Ghiscari Empire
originated before the Long Night and was still
young at the time of the cataclysm. Yi Ti
claims that it had an even older empire for
many thousands of years before that, during
the Dawn Age, but which was destroyed during
the Long Night and had to be rebuilt. The
tales of this Great Empire of the Dawn (as
it is known) are apparently mostly legend,
filled with emperors who lived for centuries
and warred with the gods. Still, only a few
generations separated the confirmed founding
of both; Old Ghis slightly before the Long
Night and Yi Ti slightly after - yet Old Ghis
was destroyed 5,000 years ago by the rising
Valyrian Freehold. In contrast, the Golden
Empire of Yi Ti is by far the oldest continuous
civilization in the world, both at present
and throughout recorded history, with culture
and accurately transmitted historical record
stretching back 8,000 years, to the end of
the Long Night. In comparison, the Ghiscari
Empire lasted about 3,000 years and the Valyrian
Freehold about 5,000 years. The civilization
of Yi Ti is therefore extremely advanced because
while it has had its share of civil wars,
its society never truly collapsed in the way
that western Essos did after the Doom of Valyria,
or experienced an effect as the Andal Invasion
had on Westeros. One Westerosi who traveled
there described Yi Ti as "the land of a thousand
gods and a hundred princes, ruled by one god-emperor."
The Empire lives in a constant state of war
against the Jogos Nhai, with many an imperial
general and three God-Emperors having led
armies across the plains to bring the nomads
to heel, but such attempts seldom ended well
and eventually, the Jogos Nhai raids began
anew. The Empire is also in danger from one
of their own Emperors who has been overthrown.
Far to the east of even more distant Asshai,
the vaguest of rumors and black legends tell
of the strange city of Carcosa, ruled by its
"Emperor in Yellow" - allegedly the last of
the Yellow Emperors of Yi Ti, overthrown and
exiled for practicing twisted dark arts. According
to the stories, the Yellow Emperor has managed
to prolong his life for a thousand years through
arcane and unspeakable magic rituals, and
he is biding his time in Carcosa until the
day when he will attempt to reclaim Yi Ti.
Others say that this is just a story told
in Yi Ti to frighten misbehaving children.
We will have to wait and see. The Game of
Thrones prequels are coming. The House of
the Dragon is the first, coming in the first
half of 2022 on HBO. Many more prequels will
follow such as 10,000 Ships, Tales of Dunk
and Egg, Robert's Rebellion, and of course
Yi Ti which is currently in development.
Thank you so much for watching.
If you enjoyed this video please give it a
big thumbs up and I hope to see you in the
next one.
Peace!